don't you just love cringing at other
people's embarrassing moments and then
shouting awkward at your screen as
awkward moments are an essential part of
growing up it's reassuring to see our
favorite characters on Nickelodeon and
the Disney Channel having their fair
share of cringe-worthy scenes and it's
even better when it's not deliberate
enjoy the nostalgia as you watch these
awkward scenes from the TV shows of your
childhood see how your favorite actors
from the likes of Victorious Jessie and
icarly made us all cringe sometimes
unintentionally and discover behind the
scenes moments you never knew about but
we're also totally awkward
please tell me that came from her mouth
and not down so extras on TV are usually
meant to blend into the background
keeping the spotlight on the stars of
the show but sometimes they do things
that grab our attention and make us
cringe just check out these extras on
Victorious thanks to this tick-tock
montage we can see when they were too
bored too energetic and just too plain
awkward if a Victoria Justice was
busting out some songs right in front of
us we do more than look bored or yawn
but to be honest who wouldn't go to the
other extreme either we wouldn't go
quite so big on the dance moves as that
guy props to him for having all that
confidence though got a love and
enthusiastic dancer right you'd think
that they'd make sure the opening theme
is totally on point given that it
appears at the beginning of every
episode but it looks like max messed up
in Wizards of Waverly Place or should we
say Jake T Austin awkwardly messed up he
looks down too early after Alex waves
her wand upwards at the title of the
show epic fail dude do you think that
Selena Gomez had fun teasing Jake about
that cringe-worthy mistake or do you
think his slip-up was on purpose either
way it certainly looks like Selena
noticed his booboo watch her nudge Jake
shoulder we know that all you eagle-eyed
bands would have spotted it too it's so
awkward when you achieve something but
someone else doesn't like when Maddie
doesn't pass her driving test and Liv
and Maddie but Liv does the cringe
factor is even higher because we see
Maddie talking about how much she wants
her license and Liv admitting that she'd
rather stay a passenger the fam has to
take down all of the congratulations
decorations is super fast then it
even more awkward when Maddie says that
she now knows what it feels like to be a
loser you know what I'm talking about
Joey a double cringe the scene just
keeps piling on the awkwardness and we
love it why would you purposefully turn
into oncoming traffic when you can go up
one block and make three rights
anyone who has mistakenly accused an ex
of still being in love with them will
know exactly how Jessie feels in this
cringeworthy scene from Jessie
in the episode called but Africa is so
far our girl makes a big error when she
misinterprets something her ex-fiance
says when the group hears a lion roar
while out on safari Brooke says
sweetheart get everyone back into the
truck Jessie thinks that he's calling
her sweetheart and calls it out you do
still love me but Brooke explains that
he was talking to kami his girlfriend
Jessie is more to fight out her mistake
even worse she said it in front of
everyone and Zuri totally nails the
atmosphere afterwards says she says
dream sequences and TV can often be
pretty cringy but freddie's dance battle
dream and icarly takes the prize as one
of the most awkward ever it's the sort
of scene you have to watch from behind
your fingers you're so embarrassed on
the actors behalf the moment that we're
talking about takes place during the
episode called I dream of Dance and it's
certainly the stuff that awkward dreams
are made of dance battles themselves
don't have to make you cringe if they're
well done but freddie's moves leave a
lot to be desired
at least he beats his competitors eek
but that's more to do with his mop
skills than his dancing skills and hey
at least he gets the girl in the end in
his dreams at least when you're
performing on stage all eyes are on you
you need to nail every single move and
unfortunately for Hilary Duff one of her
dance moves in the Lizzie McGuire Movie
stands out for all the wrong reasons
Lizzie's awkward shimmy on stage during
her what dreams are made of song got us
all cringing on her behalf the infamous
booty shake has gone down in Lizzie
McGuire history as one of the most
cringe-worthy moments we've said it once
then we'll say it again this is the
stuff that awkward dreams are made of
perhaps Lizzie and Freddy from icarly
should get together to perform the most
Awkward dance routine ever
liar the only thing I know now is I
don't know anything we're all in favor
of a family sing song it can be a really
sweet moment but sometimes it crosses
the line between sweet and awkward and
that's what happened when Dolly Parton
Billy Ray Cyrus and Miley Cyrus all sang
together on Hannah Montana don't get us
wrong
we've got fond memories of Miley's show
and we just adore Dolly Parton but
watching them have that enforced a
singsong moment makes our toes curl with
embarrassment on their behalf if you
thought it couldn't get any worse just
wait until they stop singing and say
there's even a high five talk about
fringy at least the studio audience
loved it let's go to the phones and see
what America thinks you got a feel for
Joe Jonas we all get dry lips sometimes
and it's a totally natural instinct to
quickly press them together to moisten
them up again but we don't all have to
do it during a movie scene and we don't
all have that awkward moment II
mortalized for the whole world to watch
again and again and again now all the
shame when Shane is singing gotta find
you in Camp Rock he has to sort out his
lips pronto fortunately it didn't seem
to put demi lovato off her part as
Mitchie performing this as me what a pro
Demi and to give Joey's Do's he carries
on despite the cringe-worthy moment I'm
Shane great for crying out loud
sometimes our childhood TV shows crossed
the line with something that's a bit
inappropriate for kids and that can make
for a really awkward moment just like
when Gustavo created a snickerdoodle
song and Big Time Rush
you have to listen closely to the lyrics
and then you realize that his tune is
all kinds of awkward it's those opening
lyrics when he talks about his um noodle
sure noodle can be slang for a term for
your head but it makes us cringe fun
fact I'm Steven Glickman who plays
Gustavo actually wrote the song
snickerdoodle on my noodle and he
revealed on Twitter that he gets paid
royalties every time that episode airs
nice you write songs because that's what
you love doing we've all had moments
when we've looked in a mirror out of
hair salon and wanted to cringe but
nothing beats the awkwardness of when
Luke gets a reverse mohawk in Jessie
talk about a bad hair day as Emma says
it looks like he had a fight with a
lawnmower and Luke most definitely lost
his reaction when he sees his reflection
is hilarious it's not surprising that
the hair
went wrong given that it was Bertram
rather than a professional stylist that
did it
Bertram not only did it but he also let
Luke walk out looking like an idiot in
Luke's words and Emma doesn't make him
feel any better you always look like an
idiot now you just look like an idiot
with the bad haircut burn at least
everyone else has bad hair days look a
whole lot better when someone does
something impressive it deserves a big
reaction your jaw may drop in surprise
your eyes might open wide but those
sorts of major reactions should be
reserved for seriously impressive moves
we're not talking about a little ribbon
action here which is why it's so
hilariously awkward when everyone's so
amazed by Lizzie's ribbon dance skills
in the Lizzie McGuire episode called
I've got rhythmic we couldn't help but
cringe as their jaws dropped even coach
Kelly looked like she's just watched an
Olympic performance but all Lizzie was
doing was a figure eight with a ribbon
and then a spin the slow-mo takes it to
an even more cringe-worthy level talk
about an overreaction I find the thing
I'm great at and it's a stupidest thing
in the world we also love hearing about
actors most - cringe-worthy scenes in
their behind-the-scenes revelations take
and Jason Earles for example he revealed
his most embarrassing moment on set as
Miley Cyrus's brother in Hannah Montana
he used to play a game with Miley called
the gassing go which involved passing
wind it got too awkward when another
actor got involved that was when they
filmed of the bad - the chrome episode
in season 3 with Vicki Lawrence Jason
farted in a car and Vicki didn't realize
she wanted to smell that new car smell
but got the brunt of Jason's bad smell
instead it was so bad they had to stop
taping cringe it's bad enough having one
awkward moment behind the scenes on set
but it's even more cringe-worthy when
you have several moments like Rowan
Blanchard did the actor who played Riley
in Girl Meets World repeatedly had
awkward moments on set she revealed that
nobody was as klutzy as her on the
Disney Channel show she admitted that
she's the klutzy aspersion around Rowe
and revealed that she managed to trip
going up the stairs on a daily basis she
didn't know how she did it but she
managed to do it every single day
Rowen wasn't the only one to feel
awkward messing up behind the scenes of
Girl Meets World Ben Savage who plays
Corrie also used to make cringe-worthy
mistakes too for Rowan it was being
klutzy
but for Ben the mistakes came out of his
mouth rather than his legs he admitted
that his particular area of awkwardness
had all to do with names Ben revealed
that every now and then he would mess up
the character's names in front of the
live studio audience
he'd call a character by the actors name
in the middle of the take and that meant
that they'd have to stop rolling and
start the scene again although Ben
admitted that he found it very
embarrassing to have these awkward
moments the audience had a ball watching
a mess up Miley Cyrus experienced a
major milestone on set and it created a
seriously awkward moment for the young
star the actor and singer got her first
period during the show and to make
matters even more mortifying she was
wearing white pants at the time she
revealed it was so embarrassing but she
couldn't leave as she had to be on set
so she was crying and begging her mom to
help her out poor Miley it just goes to
show that some of the most awkward
moments on our childhood TV shows
happened off screen so we never even
knew but now we do for you lots of
changes which of these awkward moments
made you cringe the most what was your
most cringe-worthy childhood moment
remember to hit that subscribe button to
be the first to hear about our new
videos thanks for watching
[Music]